in other videos we talked about how a
current flowing through a wire can
induce a magnetic field and we're going
to talk about in this video is how we
can go the other way how a change in a
magnetic field can affect or induce a
current in a loop of wire so we're going
to be going from a change change in and
actually we're going to focus on
magnetic flux magnetic magnetic flux
through a loop through through a loop
and we're going to see how this actually
induces a current in that loop so it
induces induces a current induced
current so this right over here I this
is my attempt at drawing a magnetic
field these are the magnetic field lines
they don't look like lines because
they're all popping out of the screen
they're moving towards you towards the
viewer so you could view these as the
tips of the arrow and there's different
ways of showing magnetic fields you
could show magnetic field lines like
this you could also use vectors and when
you're using field lines it's the
density of the field lines tell you how
strong the magnetic field is so if you
go to the right here they're less dense
so the magnetic field is less strong on
the right-hand side over here then they
are on the left-hand side or at least
that's what I'm trying to depict now if
we digit with vectors we would have
bigger arrows pointing out over here
than we would over there but now let's
do a a loop of let's do a loop of wire
let me draw a loop of wire here so let's
say I have a loop of wire that is so
this is my loop of wire my loop of wire
so if I just throw that loop of wire and
if it's just stationary and it's in this
magnetic field and the magnetic field
isn't changing I do have some flux going
through the I guess you say the surface
defined by this wire and if you're
unfamiliar with the term magnetic flux I
encourage you to watch the video on
magnetic flux but if I just have this
wire stationary in the magnetic field
nothing is going to happen but I will be
able to induce a current if I change the
magnetic flux going through this
surface in some way so for example right
now the magnetic field is pointing out
of the screen if I were to make it even
stronger in the direction pointing out
of the screen so I guess one way to
think about it is if I were to if the
change in the magnetic field the change
in the flux were to get even stronger in
the outward direction so I don't know a
good way to so it's going to get even
stronger in the outer direction I'll
draw a big error there I guess you could
say that these these things became even
denser in this outward direction it is
actually going to induce a current and
the current that it will induce is going
to go is going to go in that direction
and let me draw a little bit clearer the
current is going to go in that direction
it's going to go in a clockwise
direction around this and that is
because that change in the magnetic flux
that induces a voltage an electromotive
force that causes this current to flow
that causes the current to flow and
there's other ways to change the
magnetic flux if I were to if I were to
lessen the magnetic field in the outward
direction or another way if the change
in the magnetic field were inwards then
the current would go the other direction
but the key here is when I change the
flux through this through this surface
defined by this wire it's going to
induce a current the current isn't going
to be there if the thing is if the
magnetic field is stationary and I'm not
changing this this this loop in any way
but as soon as I change the flux in some
way I am going to induce a current I
could also instead of changing the field
I could actually move my I could
actually move my coil I could move it
that way and if I were to move it that
way the flux going through this surface
or rag is coming out of this surface
will increase because if I move this to
the left the magnetic field is denser I
guess it's stronger so there'll be more
flux through this area here so if you
move it that way
you also would have a current like this
now if you moved it the other way if it
was on the left hand side and you moved
it that way it would also induce a
current but now since the flux is
lessening in the outward direction the
current would go in the other way now
there's other ways to change the flux
you could actually change the area
of this actual loop if somehow it was
made out of some maybe stretchy stretchy
wire somehow if you if you increased its
if you had increased let me draw it this
way if you are somehow able to stretch
it stretch it so it contains so the SIRT
the actual area increases if you're able
to stretch it out so that the actual
area increases which would cause the
flux in the out of the screen direction
to increase even more that also would
induce that also would induce the
current and so this whole idea of a
change in magnetic flux inducing a
current this is the essence and we'll go
deeper into it in future videos this is
the essence of Faraday's law Faraday's
Faraday's Faraday's law and will
quantify this more in future videos but
it's just the notion that if I have a
loop of wire and I have a changing
magnetic flux through the loop of wire
that is going to induce a current in
that wire